l'ambassade de france à beyrouth
encerclée par l'armée libanaise vouziers
de protection d'après la présidence mais
michel aoun et y est toujours réfugié
de personnes à l'appel du père et du cds
manifestent à paris pour le retour de
michel aoun en france invité du livre
par françois nova
grève nationale et manifestations un peu
partout en france la sécu est dans la
rue salaires et classification à la une
des revendications
elle avait un charme énigmatique un
talent reconnu par tous delphine seyrig
nous a quittés elle avait 58 ans bonsoir
le général chrétien michel aoun qui se
trouvent toujours à l'ambassade de
france à beyrouth doit éprouver ce soir
un sentiment mêlé d'espoir et d'angoissé
d'espoir à la suite de la mise au point
hier de françois mitterrand la france ne
le livrera pas au gouvernement libanais
dans goas à la suite de la réplique
aujourd'hui des autorités libanaises qui
n'ont pas changé d'avis elles veulent
juger le général aoun et pour bien
montrer leur détermination ont ordonné à
l'armée d'encercler l'ambassade de
france et dix pisteurs 11 heures locales
ce matin une unité de l'armée libanaise
se met en place devant l'ambassade de
france une demi heure après cette force
va reculer installé un barrage à une
centaine de mètres de l'entrée de la
représentation française
officiellement selon porte parole de la
présidence ibanez ses troupes ne sont là
que pour protéger l'ambassade
d'éventuelles manifestations anti aoun
mais visiblement après que françois
mitterrand est déclaré hier que l'asile
accordé au général était une question
d'honneur le ton s'envenime entre paris
et les autorités libanaises et cela
malgré les démarches répétées de rené
allard
l'ambassadeur de france rencontre hier
soir avec le président hraoui puis ce
matin avec sélim hoss le premier
ministre et cet après midi pour la
troisième fois nouvelle rencontre avec
le président libanais si le chef de
gouvernement sélim hoss est apparue
conciliant déclarant que les autorités
libanaises n'avait toujours pas pris de
décision définitive quant au sort de
michel aoun
d'autres ministres notamment pro syriens
ont été plus catégorique le général doit
être jugé pas question qu'il quitte le
pays
edmond risque le ministre de la justice
est très clair lui aussi je le cite les
motivations humanitaires pour accorder
l'asile diplomatique au général aoun ne
sont plus justifiés et le sort réservé
au général aoun a provoqué une
manifestation à paris à l'appel du père
et du cds plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont en effet défilé devant
l'ambassade du
bon à paris c'était il y à quelques
minutes ils demandaient le retour du
général chrétien et laitiers en france
parmi eux françois léotard est
précisément françois léotard est
l'invité du 19/20 bonsoir bonsoir
provient du cortège
je viens à l'instant de nouveaux
services de proximité de l'ambassade de
nous avons manifesté pour apporter notre
soutien au peuple libanais tout entier
chrétiens et musulmans bien entendu dans
son honneur dans sa dignité et pour
apporter aussi haut mais ce général aoun
un message de fraternité
mais pourquoi cette manifestation ont
dit être rassurés par les banques en cas
de lumière françois mitterrand la france
même livrera pas au gouvernement
libanais j'ai trouvé ces propos
extrêmement dignes et il faut absolument
que le gouvernement français ne change
pas d'un pouce à position les pressions
vont être très forte
il faut que nous mettions un peuple ce
n'est pas simplement des choses
matérielles il faut que nous mettions
notre honneur notre dignité de deux
nations dans le fait que quand quelqu'un
demande l'asile politique
quand quelqu'un de aussi respectable en
plus que le général aoun et bien
l'ensemble du peuple français pas
simplement ses gouvernants 10
vous n'y touche répond il faut que ce
soit une règle le constant pendant les
semaines à venir si ça peut durer
plusieurs années ça durera plusieurs
années il faut bien que nos auditeurs
libanais et ceux qui sont là bas le
sache
vous dites les propos de françois
mitterrand était digne ça veut dire que
vous ne remettez pas en cause le
consensus actuel sur la politique
étrangère de la france sur ce trou
imprécis du général aoun vous savez
combien je regrette que la france n'ait
pas dit plus clairement qu' il faut y
avoir un gouvernement légal actuel
mais quand on est un gouvernement légal
on n'est pas nécessairement un
gouvernement légitime
la france a connu ça pendant la guerre
le gouvernement du maréchal pétain était
d'après les règles françaises légales il
n'était pas légitime et c'était le
général de gaulle qui incarnait la
légitimité
nous pensons la même chose pour le
général aoun et par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui au liban qui est tenu comme
j'allais dire comme un pendule est
soutenue par sa corde par les chars
syriens dans l'aviation syrienne pour
les soldats ciani vous avez combien
valéry giscard d'estaing cette
manifestation oui ils savaient que ça va
mieux mais j'imagine que ces charges
sont très grand vous savez alors je ne
fais pas de nom je ne fais pas de deux
pôles il ya beaucoup de parlementaires
beaucoup de parlementaires et je suis
même pas sûr qu'il était aujourd'hui en
france 3 qu'il avait un voyage
international dont je ne fais aucune
aucune remarque de ce génocide arrêtez
vous avait convié le maire faire cette
manipulation oui il y avait eu j'ai vu
la parlementaire rpr je crois qu'elle
avait deux cas la situation est
paradoxale elle un peu complexe il ya
consensus entre disons françois
mitterrand et l'opposition mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'ils aient ce consensus
au sein même de l'opposition j'ai
l'impression que les patients ne crois
pas il peut y avoir par exemple une
différence d'appréciation sur les
accords de taëf qui sont à l'origine
même du drame libanais c'est possible on
le verra demain où il ya plusieurs
questions d'actualité dans ce sens à
l'assemblée
mais globalement l'opposition est je
crois une partie de la majorité
partagent le sentiment d'indignation de
voir un pays ami comme l'est le liban
qui parlent notre langue qui se tournent
vers nous aujourd'hui occupée
massivement par une armée étrangère et
qui est ignorée par la communauté des
nations
nous poussons des grands cris sur
jérusalem probablement faut-il le faire
nous mettons des troupes au large du
koweït probablement faut-il le faire et
nous laissons massacre et asservir un
peuple et un peuple ami qui s'appelle le
liban et avec lequel nous avons des
liens séculaires de fraternité et
d'amitié
s'il ne faut pas laisser le fait c'est
pas 4 la faille dans le camp occidental
on condamne l'irak mais il ya comme un
arrangement avec damas oui je ne pense
pas que les ennemis de mes ennemis
soient mes amis quand monsieur assad
soutient ce que nous sommes en train de
faire dans le golfe ce n'est pas pour
autant qu'il est un de nos amis monsieur
stade est un dictateur sanglant qui
menacent en permanence l'identité
d'israël qui est un qui ne partagent pas
du tout nos valeurs qui occupe
aujourd'hui la plaine de la bekaa les
deux tiers ou les trois quarts du pays
libanais du liban nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de considérer comme un de nos
amis et ce n'est pas parce qu'il est
aujourd'hui opposés monsieur saddam
hussein que par ce fait même il devient
quelqu'un de respectable et de
fréquentable ce n'est pas mon opinion
merci françois lyotard la situation au
liban fait oublier la crise du golfe
mais on aurait tort de penser que cette
crise est moins aigu aujourd'hui
l'accalmie est trompeuse
les etats unis ont ainsi rejeté
officiellement toute idée de solution
partielle
c'est à dire de retrait partiel du
koweït et les pays impliqués restent
tous vigiles
vigilance sécurité renforcée depuis le
début de la crise des mesures
supplémentaires ont été mises en place
en france
ainsi à roissy une brigade spéciale de
la police de l'air et des frontières
passent au peigne fin les bagages mais
aussi les avions et les passagers
une brigade bien sûr spécialisée dans
les risques d'attentats reportage à
roissy de jean françois grégoire et
christophe airaud une mallette oublié
dans le hall des départs de roissy 1
un objet suspect qui doit être détruit
exercice quasi quotidiens pour les
services de déminage de l'aéroport
depuis le début de la crise du golfe
la fréquence des exercices visant à
assurer la sécurité des passagers a
augmenté ainsi les responsables de la
paf la police de l'air et des frontières
they still eux mêmes la concentration de
leurs hommes chargés du contrôle des
bagages à main par rayons x
une jeune inspectrice va tenter de
s'embarquer avec un engin piégé caché
dans son sac
les deux policiers auxiliaires ne se
sont pas laissés tromper
et d'après la police de l'air 80 % des
tentatives monté par ses services sont
interceptés en revanche une grande
partie des bagages assoute ne passe
toujours pas aux rayons x
sauf sur les compagnies américaines et
sur les vols dits sensibles dont les
passagers doivent en plus subir un
questionnaire serré
et puis la police de l'air et des
frontières vient de créer une compagnie
d'intervention qui peut venir contrôler
un vol à tout moment de a à z contrôles
d'identité fouilles des valises suivi
des passagers jusque dans l'avion où le
travail du chien est encore le plus sûr
moyen de prévenir un attentat
consciente qu'une complicité peut naître
parmi les trente cinq mille personnes
qui travaillent à roissy la paf a
également renforcé le contrôle du
personnel obligatoirement badgés ceci
étant notre action ne se limite pas à
cela
on a aussi une marge de manoeuvre
imprévu de façon à à ce que l'adversaire
éventuel celui qui aurait envie de
d'observer comment les choses se passent
sur notre aéroport pour commettre une
action illicite bien soit un peu
désorienté dans cet objectif 10
inspecteurs du renseignement passent
leur temps dans les couloirs des
aéroports à tout observer à toute
analyse est le fruit de leur travail
servira ensuite à renforcer la
dissuasion contre la menace terroriste à
roissy en france l'actualité marquée par
un conflit social donc par un défilé
celui de la sécu on garde nationale et
manifestations dans toute la france la
sécu est redescendu dans la rue ils
étaient plus de dix mille aujourd'hui à
paris principale revendication les
salaires et la grille de classification
les agents en grève cherche toujours
désespérément un interlocuteur
reportage de marie élaine michaud et
dominique duchateau l'éducation de
toutes les caisses de la sécurité
sociale venus de tous les départements
sont montés à paris en tête l'essonne
dont les salariés ont décidé de
suspendre leur mouvement de grève après
quatre mois ils ont accepté les
propositions de la caisse nationale
promotion nombreuses et augmentation des
plus bas salaires
aujourd'hui journée d'action nationale
les salariés réclament toujours un
rattrapage de leur pouvoir d'achat et
une nouvelle grille de classification
des mains pas de grève au programme mais
reprise des actions locales en
particulier dans de nombreuses caisses
les salariés ont décidé de traiter très
minutieusement les dossiers nous sommes
engagés à la perrière bordeaux sur une
action de meilleure qualité du travail
c'est-à-dire de remplir les feuilles de
soin d'une façon
correct ça nous fait une baisse de
production assez importante et nous
continuerons ce mouvement quelle est la
baisse de production d or peu près 30
30% de baisse
question pour les salariés avec qui
négocier luc ans l'organisme qui gère le
personnel sait qu a éclaté avec la
démission d'une partie de ses
administrateurs syndicats et patronat le
cnpf ne souhaite pas revenir après
matignon les salariés ont manifesté
devant l'elysée sans plus de succès sans
lui quand s'il leur est ce le ministre
de la santé mais le gouvernement refuse
toute augmentation supérieure à celle
des fonctionnaires
vous aurez peut-être du mal à trouver de
l'argent ces prochains jo il ya en effet
une pénurie de liquide à paris et dans
certain nombre de grandes villes en
france une conséquence de la grève des
convoyeurs qui ne s'estiment pas assez
payer pour les risques encourus
les fonds ne sont plus transporter les
banques commencent à manquer d'argent
liquide les consommateurs aussi
reportage de martine siebold ai marre
que nous révolution chez les taxis
parisiens avec la pénurie d'argent
liquide qui commence à se faire sentir
ils vont être obligés d'accepter les
chèques bien sûr nous sommes et c'est
plutôt contraint et forcé car
l'enthousiasmé n'y ait pas ces
pourparlers 15 francs front 18 front on
sait que ça fait mal
cela fait maintenant une semaine que la
grève des convoyeurs de fonds a commencé
conséquence dans les banques on manque
de plus en plus d'un joli kid et la
plupart des distributeurs de billets
sont vides ccrg fait d'un effet combien
no 4 pour les parisiens de trouver de
l'argent liquide devient de plus en plus
un parcours du combattant mais la
situation varie d'une banque à l'autre
certaines sont contraintes de limiter
les retraits à 500 francs dans les
billetteries aux guichets des clients ne
peuvent pas toujours retirer les sommes
qu'il souhaite et c'est surtout pour les
petits achats chez les commerçants que
ça se complique
si long que pour 45 franc je rends 500
je leur donne 5
enfin il me faut un petit chèque de 50
ha dont je connais bien c'est un grand
avantage pour un chèque de 35 à 40 j'ai
pas de solution pour les banquiers ou à
la poste la situation est compliquée
mais pas encore dramatique on gère la
pénurie pour l'instant si vous et
normalement je tiens encore deux trois
jours comme ça tranquillement je pense
sans problème par rapport à ça sens
propre tout dépend maintenant de l'issue
du conflit qui oppose convoyeur de fonds
est banquier
rien ne devrait se débloquer avant les
négociations de jeudi
conséquences en france de la crise du
golfe c'est à dire de l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole la hausse des prix en
septembre a été plus forte que prévu en
septembre comme en août l'indicé des
prix a fait un bond de 0 5 % peut-être
même de 0 26% selon les chiffres
provisoires de l'insee avec ce mauvais
résultat
la hausse des prix depuis le début de
l'année dépasse les 3% en rythme annuel
sur les douze derniers mois l'inflation
frôle même les 4%
commentaire du ministère de l'économie
les facteurs internes de l'inflation
demeure pour l'instant maîtrisé sans la
hausse du pétrole les prix n'auraient
augmenté que de 0 2% en septembre
cette hausse des prix n'a pas fait
l'objet de controverses à l'assemblée
nationale qui étudie à partir
d'aujourd'hui le projet de budget du
gouvernement rocard ce projet ne
satisfait pas l'opposition qui refuse
notamment la contribution sociale
généralisée et cela michel rocard s'y
attendait mais ce qui doit le
préoccupait davantage ce sont les
réticences exprimées au sein même de la
majorité
michel le maire victor arish le rpr part
en guerre contre le budget de pierre
bérégovoy de l'exception
d'irrecevabilité qui vient d'être
repoussée à la motion de renvoi il est
bien décidé à utiliser toute la panoplie
de la procédure parlementaire
pour mener sa guérilla qui me paraît
très critiquable c'est la philosophie
même général de ce budget qui se situe
dans la droite ligne de ce qui a été
fait en 88 d'environ 20 9
on est pense qu on se désendette pas
assez et la politique fiscale de ce
gouvernement est un non-sens centriste
et udf un peu pris de vitesse par la
furia rpr ne s'associe pas à toutes les
procédures
pas question non plus pour le pc
d'utiliser ce genre de munitions
résultat le gouvernement ne paraît pas
trop inquiet sur ces escarmouches
réglementaire en revanche sur le fond il
a quelques soucis à se faire
il n'a pas actuellement de majorité pour
faire voter son budget les centristes
proposent un contre-projet et le pc
refuse ce tel qu'il est je rappelle le
but de projet de budget nous votre
encontre
il y à terme du 49-3 dans l'air pour
l'heure l'assemblée se prépare cette
nuit à une guerre d'usure
la rentrée universitaire se passe plutôt
bien pour le moment mais c'est presque
une surprise cent mille étudiants
supplémentaires arrivent en effet cette
année et malgré le plan d'urgence
déclenché par le gouvernement les
universités sont de plus en plus à
l'étroit
c'est le cas à caen en normandie où on
en accueille deux fois plus d'élèves que
prévu enquête sur place de marie adine
pas nièce et christophe airaud rentrée
88 la grogne rentrée 89 la colère
l'université de caen n'en peut plus peu
de crédit des locaux trop petits
la suite si cette année quand accueil
malgré tout ces vingt-trois mille
étudiants pour 12000 places dans un
calme précaire l'université cache sa
misère il manque 10 est professeur
d'anglais
la rentrée des élèves en langue vivante
et retarder les cours prévus en premier
cycle scientifique supprimer les moyens
sont déjà insuffisants on pioche dans
les finances réservé à la fin de l'année
du bricolage au jour le jour qui risque
de ne pas faire illusion longtemps ça
risque d'être encore une année difficile
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu encore de
réaction mais à d'habitude elles
viennent un peu plus tard
vers la fin d'octobre courant novembre
ciblés avec des revendications sur
talent et un point qui vont pas des
locaux surchargées des amphis surchargés
c'est personnel d'encadrement dans les
salles de tp cette année le taux de
réussite au bac a augmenté conséquence
15 % d'inscrits supplémentaires dans les
disciplines scientifiques par exemple
l'université ne suit plus il y à un
manque de professeurs dans toutes les
matières dans ces conditions les chèques
en première année des universités ne
peut qu'aller croissant avec les
populations qui deviennent de plus en
plus nombreuses une inquiétude qui n'a
pas encore contaminé les nouveaux
étudiants comme s'il était déjà trop
conscient des problèmes comme s'il
tentait d'intégrer la théorie du c'est
comme ça de gagner oui c'est un problème
puisque ces comportements chargé
conférant un tueur à moins de compter
sur l'abandon des autres pour vous faire
votre non pas forcément mais en général
ça se passe comme ça
la formation ça dépend plus de moi je
m'adapte aux à ce qu'on propose quand
même si c'est le jeu un peu le le
désordre d'essayer de faire ce que je
peux quarante pour cent de ces nouveaux
inscrits abandonneront leurs études dès
la première année en partie à cause des
problèmes d'accueil des universités
difficile d'imaginer qu'en l'an 2000
enfants ce sont deux millions
d'étudiants qu'il faudra former
grisaille à toulon le club de football
risquent de descendre en division 3 pour
une histoire de gros sous de gros sous
qui mentent la caisse reste en effet
désespérément vide
à la différence de la municipalité de
bordeaux celle de toulon refuse
d'éponger le passif qui s'élève à 70
millions de francs un homme très attendu
le pdg bernard gonthier candidat à la
reprise du sporting club de toulon et du
var face au conseil municipal hier soir
bernard cantier est l'homme de la
dernière chance pour la ville le conseil
général et les dirigeants du club
il s'agit en effet de combler un déficit
de 71 millions de francs
bernard quand il reste inflexible il ne
paiera pas
ici est capable d'avancer un rond dans
un déficit c'est pas possible
les structures à l'heure actuelle du
football français ne permet pas un
entrepreneur privé de jouer de l'argent
sur un déficit
derrière la porte close le conseil
municipal délibère si bernard quand il
ne veut pas prendre en charge une partie
du déficit la ville elle non plus n'est
pont sera pas la dette
le sporting est condamné et la mairie
estime n'être pour rien si les
responsables des mouvements de fonds si
les responsables de la fixation des
contrats et des salaires si les
responsables des transferts et vous avez
vu comment s'organisent les transferts
en forme c'est absolument ahurissant ne
produisent pas les pièces et fort au
finalement roues des fausses factures ou
des dissimulations de fond le meilleur
contrôleur du monde qu'ils soient
comptables ou qu'il soit un
administrateur qui soit qu'on s'immisce
ipa avec qu'il soit le p cannes la rue
il y voit que du bleu françois trucy
sauvé selon vous pour moi je pense qu'il
est au courant de toutes les
transactions financières qui est
effectué par le club
je dirais que je répète il y avait un
comptable cette même personne était
expert comptable pour la ville et en
tout état de cause l'expert comptable
s'occupe également de toutes les
associations de la ville
alors si aujourd'hui on dit que y'avait
pas de rapports comptables effectué pour
la ville alors je me demande laquelle et
la fiabilité des autres associations qui
jettent y sont dans la ville de toulon
qui sont pour la ville de toulon reste
aujourd'hui un énorme gâchis
une équipe de football sans avenir un
déficit de 71 millions de francs
un probable dépôt de bilan et aussi le
sentiment pour toulon d'être devenu le
bouc émissaire d'un football français
malade de l'argent sport et politique
toujours la loi evin sur l'alcool et le
tabac n'est pas encore votée les deux
sur discuté au sénat mais elle a déjà
des conséquences martini en effet décidé
de stopper net son partenariat dans le
sport en france
les fabricants de cigarettes et d'alcool
bénéficiait pourtant d'un moratoire
jusqu'en 93 les flèches l'effet le plus
immédiat est le plus marquant c'est la
disparition du sigle martini du capot
des voitures de rallye jean philippe
djian les spectateurs des rallyes
français ne pourront plus reconnaître et
lancia à leur célèbre logo avant même la
date fatidique de janvier 93
la firme marquigny rossi a décidé
aujourd'hui de devancer le projet de loi
evin qui vise l'interdiction de la
publicité pour les tabacs et sa
limitation sur les alcools
un contexte présent où la loi est sur le
point d'être votée dans toute sa rigueur
et dans un contexte beaucoup plus
difficile que par le passé il est
évident que toute société qui continuera
un sponsoring sportif se mettraient de
fait dans l'illégalité
si le projet de loi actuel est votée
telle quelle la firme était surtout
engagé auprès de la fédération des
scream et depuis 38 ans le challenge
martini était le fleuron de son
partenariat sportif
pour l'année prochaine la fédération
devra donc trouver un nouveau partenaire
financier début de solution l'apparition
de logos publicitaires sur la tenue
immaculée des escrimeurs mais au delà de
ce simple exemple le retrait d'al
collier comme martini suivi
éventuellement de celui de fabricants de
cigarette met en péril l'avenir d'au
moins deux grandes disciplines
l'automobile est la moto en effet la
publicité consentis par le tabac et
l'alcool représente un investissement de
2 milliards de francs
et même si la loi evin prévoit une
période transitoire jusqu'en janvier 93
et nouveaux sponsors susceptibles de
remplacer marlboro ou gitane ne sont pas
légion les champions concernés l'ont
vite compris
conscient du danger il demande au
gouvernement de ne pas trancher trop
vite
le débat promet d'être vie
clément weill-raynal résume les autres
événements du jour la grève des
camionneurs espagnol à la frontière
entre la france et l'espagne entraîne un
blocage routier jusqu'à bordeaux
plus de 500 poids-lourds qui ne peuvent
rejoindre la frontière stationnent sur
la zone de fret de la ville une zone de
fret au bord de la saturation
par ailleurs la sncf a annoncé l'arrêt
total du trafic marchandises en raison
du blocus
enfin en espagne la grève commence à
poser dans certaines régions de sérieux
problèmes d'approvisionnement en denrées
périssables
bref tout est bloqué
incendie criminel dans un lycée
technique de nice l'un des 30 bâtiments
en préfabriqué a été entièrement détruit
hier soir le lycée réputé pour sa
vétusté et les nombreux incidents
violents qui sont fréquemment déroulé
la grève des bus de la région parisienne
se poursuit une grève qui affecte 40 %
du trafic selon la direction de la ratp
les machinistes en grève réclament un
accroissement des mesures de sécurité
notamment après 20 heures en raison des
nombreuses agressions subies ces
derniers mois trois morts et 18 blessés
dont deux graves dans un accident de car
cette nuit sur l'autoroute a10 à
proximité de tours pour une raison
encore indéterminée l'autocar qui venait
de paris et se rendaient rabat au maroc
a quitté la chaussée et s'est couché sur
le bas-côté savoie va nous manquer sa
voix si singulière et si attachant
delphine seyrig est morte aujourd'hui
théâtre cinéma elle avait séduit les
plus grands réalisateurs françois
truffaut alain resnais ou marguerite
duras elle avait été révélée en 1960
dans l'année dernière à marienbad sa
dernière apparition
c'était il ya quelques mois au théâtre à
paris marie claire gauthier est elle à
70,87 théâtre de la renaissance
répétition de sa dernière pièce un
jardin en désordre elle était à part et
elle le savait c'était un choix elle le
disait avec cette conscience de ce que
sa notoriété apportée au tfc rien en soi
c'est le fait que si ça si vous voulez
et il se trouve que pour le théâtre ça
aide à faire venir le public au cinéma
rialto dont deux producteurs cinéma ça
ne nous aide pas du tout maintenant sur
la fesci stocks au théâtre ça aide
tant mieux de marienbad signalant
rennais au cri de la langouste où elle
incarne et sarah bernhardt en passant
par la bête dans la jungle d'henry james
elle avait choisi la rigueur mais elle
n'était pas dupe c'est pas moi c'est les
tickets moi j'étais échangé beaucoup de
style
si je vous disais extrêmement
différentes si vous voyez vous on crée
killen vite et vous voyez que j'ai fait
des choses aussi différentes que
possible les unes des autres
donc je ne sais pas et pas question pour
moi de ne pas changer puisque change à
chaque fois dans quelques secondes 10
heures à 20 heures le rappel des titres
du 19/20 paris et beyrouth pomme de
discorde entre les deux pays le sort du
général déchu michel aoun toujours
réfugié dans l'ambassade de france à
beyrouth des locaux encerclée depuis ce
matin par l'armée libanaise convergence
de vues entre françois léotard et
françois mitterrand sur le soutien
apporté à michel aoun un soutien qui
doit rester constant malgré les
pressions en revanche pour le président
du parti républicain si le gouvernement
libanais est légal
il n'est pas forcément légitime
parrot honneurs de la sécu plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'agents de la
sécurité sociale manifesté à paris
aujourd'hui pour réclamer des
augmentations salariales et une réforme
de la grille des salariés à la recherche
d'un interlocuteur
présentation du projet de budget pour
1991 par pierre bérégovoy l'assemblée
nationale un budget qui n'a pas été voté
par les trois groupes de l'opposition
rpr udf et udc il y à du 49 3 en l'air
et il y aura de nouvelles informations
dans le journal présenté par marc
hautement à 22h15 ce sera soir 3 avant
cela sur l'a3 dans quelques instants la
classe avec du rire et à 20h40 du cinéma
avec un téléfilm la tendresse de
l'araignée avec bernadette lafont et à
23h25 très important le deuxième volet
de grand reporter une série en quatre
épisodes série documentaire sur
l'honneur du journaliste dans quelques
secondes très important la page météo
complet